[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to the 2018 what's on my
smartphone video uh now i'm pretty sure
i've mentioned at least once or twice in
previous videos that my setup does not
change that much from year to year on my
phone now fair warning to those of you
who saw last year's video a lot of the
apps are going to look very similar to
that
i didn't do this video over and over
again because what's on my phone was
mostly the same
the setup i have uh is usually pretty
simple and this is because i switch
phones pretty often during the course of
the year nevertheless here we are people
have asked for it i'm showing it to you
again one of the more interesting
questions i get from friends like
outside of this is isn't it annoying to
change your phone like switch your whole
setup and transfer everything over and
over again every time you change phones
isn't that annoying after a while
and the answer is
yes but i've kind of streamlined it in a
way i mean google handles a lot of the
migration of that stuff usually it's not
that big of a deal and then i kind of
streamline it so it's nearly the same
every time and i know exactly when i'm
done setting everything up but anyway
i'm carrying two phones as i've
mentioned and i did last year uh two
pockets two phones and it's my favorite
android phone right now and my favorite
iphone right now same thing as last year
so this iphone 10 in silver is my second
most used phone it's good for a lot of
those camera things like snapchat
instagram live the occasional periscope
things that ios is good at there's also
a couple of apps some specific vr games
and things like that that are only on
ios right now so i just kind of always
have an iphone in my pocket but if you
saw lose video from ces a couple weeks
ago earlier this year then you already
know that the main phone in my pocket is
the panda google pixel 2 xl but i still
love this phone for all those same
reasons that i loved back when i
reviewed it a couple months ago and i
keep coming back to it for those same
reasons so uh this is my setup all right
so first of all wallpaper i'll
definitely link that below people have
asked about it i've tweeted about it
recently it's a little bit of a blue
canyon but this is the setup to start
and i'll just give you that sort of a
walk through basically i've said this
before but i use the google stock
launcher for a couple of reasons but
mainly because a lot of the features
that end up getting really popular and
are really useful and third-party apps
like nova launcher slowly make their way
into this stock launcher now this side
piece here with the google news and all
these cards
it's it's decently useful but i use it a
little bit less because it's actually
gotten worse you can't swipe away cards
anymore like if you're not interested in
something
you can't swipe it away to get rid of it
and that's pretty annoying so it just
kind of ends up filled with things that
i'm not interested in which is pretty
dumb you should let us remove stuff like
this what is i don't i don't care about
half of this stuff anyway this is the
home screen i got the weather up top and
the date that's cool i don't really use
a whole ton of space so you can see
again like i mentioned it's pretty darn
similar to the last time i showed it so
here's my apps at the bottom i switched
to tiktik which is my task manager app
now
it's really clean and it syncs with
itself it doesn't really use google
tasks but it's still pretty good and
then i use google keep to manage lists
like grocery lists so those are the two
must use apps for me instagram you all
are familiar with that i use it all the
time yahoo fantasy sports uh i'm doing
a lot worse this year than i was in
previous years although i do think oh
it's a new week but i did win my last
week uh which is pretty good my fantasy
team is uh it's all right
i had a late pick what are you gonna do
there's google photos there's google
maps there's youtube studio i think
pretty much every youtuber ever has
youtube studio uh on their phone you can
use it to answer comments keep track of
videos things like that that's all there
spotify my number one music player of
choice the tesla app that's how you warm
up your car before you go outside in the
freezing cold to get to it
and all the other management stuff i've
done a video all on that app and then
relay pro which is my reddit app of
choice people seem to ask every time i
show this like why do you use relay pro
yes there are other pretty good reddit
apps for android this one just happens
to be really familiar to me at this
point um
but anyway i also use this to manage the
mkbhd subreddit which we're using a
little bit more now if you head over to
rmkbhd we're starting to experiment with
that getting video suggestions there and
things like that so uh i'll link that
below if you're interested and of course
at the bottom are the mainstays the
phone the messenger the play store
the camera app and then flamingo is my
twitter app of choice i'm pretty sure
when i did this video last time of the
year it was phoenix uh they started
messing around with a beta that i'm not
as interested in but flamingo which is
another bird is another twitter app for
android that's really good remembers my
spot in the timeline it does everything
well it's pretty it's pretty material
it's good so flamengo i'll link i'll
link that below as well now i'm going to
swipe over to my second home screen here
and this is my calendar app the full
screen calendar widget it's the exact
same that i used last time i was showing
my phone but you'll notice it's kind of
buggy now i can turn up the opacity and
stuff to show this better depending on
my wallpaper but i'm cool with it
because it always highlights the top one
but it always says loading at the top of
each day loading loading that's not
because it's actually loading that's
just an android 8.0 bug that this app
just has now i haven't switched to
another full screen calendar widget
because i still like the looks and the
functionality of this one and how good
it is i use google calendar for my life
but if you're a developer of this app
can you can you please update this for
android 8.0 please i'd really like it to
actually say the date above each day
thank you anyway going over to the third
and final home screen it's the shortcuts
that i use just the apps that i'm using
pretty often around now so wallet paypal
and passes i don't even use google
wallet that often but this passes app i
use literally just because of the car
wash i go to which happens to have a
royalty program every 10 car washes you
get an 11.3
it doesn't work with google wallet so i
use passes i think it's actually meant
for iphone and then dark sky for weather
this is another one that started off
really popular as an iphone app that's
made its way over to android over the
years it's almost as good on android as
it is on ios it still has some bugs
though but my main weather app is
accuweather as you'll see when i go to
my app drawer
we have waze i discovered this recently
like in the past year turns out it's an
incredible app for avoiding traffic
and avoiding tickets nest i've showed
that before i've got a couple nest
cameras that's the security suite that's
the thermostat that whole thing the
authenticator app pocket cast is pretty
new to me i guess basically during
flights i have to figure out a way to
pass the time uh and music kind of gets
old after a long time so the pocket cast
app with a couple good podcasts can be
pretty good if you have any good podcast
suggestions definitely hit me up in the
comments below i have the united app
that's just because i fly united a lot
and my boarding pass is in there the
healthmate app from nokia this actually
used to be something else but then nokia
bought them and then now i have a scale
that like talks to the app it tells me
how much
it's whatever and then the google home
app which is all the google home devices
you have of course if you have the
shopping list i think they ruin the
shopping list i just want to rant about
that for a second you used to be able to
say talk to google and add something to
your shopping list and then it would
show up in google keep in a list called
shopping list now if you want to add
something to your shopping list for some
weird reason they changed it to show up
in here
inside the shopping list which opens in
your web browser to this shopping
list.google.com
why they did this
i will probably never know they should
definitely switch it back to talking to
google keep anyway last but not least
youtube it's a pretty uh
pretty great site i've found recently
they do some some interesting stuff over
here if you want to check it out they
host a lot of videos i'll share a link
below but that's basically it for the
home screen layout those are the apps
the shortcuts you see pretty often those
are the things i'm clicking the most
anyway i'll finish it up with the uh the
last scroll through all the apps that
you know i have on my phone but didn't
make it to my home screen again a lot of
stuff pretty similar to last year but my
main weather app of choice is
accuweather platinum it's super accurate
and it's awesome i also have aftership
up here in my most recent that's pretty
good for tracking just about any package
anytime you copy a tracking number to
your clipboard and open up after ship it
asks you if you want to paste it and
track it it's really good it sinks
across platforms backdrops is again
still pretty awesome for finding
wallpapers chrome canary is also a lot
of fun uh fun for showing new features
that are coming to the main version of
chrome but also it's unstable it's super
it literally has unstable in the name
it's hilarious i have coinbase that's a
thing that's
new to me obviously cryptocurrency in
the past year or two let's see you got
daydream vr
dropbox is pretty common
uh you have the jaybird sound app for
messing with the sound of your
headphones the nba app i it's it's all
right it gives me notifications when
cool things happen but scrolling down
that's pretty much it i have pocket i do
use that a lot screener i use once in a
while but it's awesome for sharing
screenshots that are really pretty and i
get down here to uber and venmo and zoc
dock and youtube tv and uh that's pretty
much it for the setup on my main phone
like i said it's pretty similar to the
last year but if you don't know now you
know people were asking for it so now
you have it maybe in a year if my setup
is actually different i'll be able to
share that but for the most part i'm
expecting it to stay
roughly similar so i'll link you to this
video how's that
so that's it thank you for watching talk
to you guys the next one peace